it's
about trying to see what cloud computing
if it is brought to the the realm of
data science
and to the python world and to the our
world can bring
to you data scientists developers
teachers
the idea was to say using the cloud is
not just
having a server somewhere it's about
having new capabilities
having the way to get the infrastructure
becomes
programmable and becomes part of the
software itself
so this work was started in
collaboration with
with people from the e-science program
in the uk
and i will give you some context as an
as a
an introduction then i will
show you what what i came up with as
new ideas and concepts that could help
in getting the cloud
useful to you and and then i will show
you demos and then we will
try to to engage and to to do things
for real using amazon's cloud
so
most of you here are aware that we are
today facing new challenges
related to big data those challenges
are are really enormous in many
domains but they are really one of the
biggest challenges
for scientists this is something that
people show when they talk about the
challenges of e-science
basically they they we often mention the
fact that science
started being experimental we moved to
theoretical science
and then came the age of computers and
we started having
a computational challenges done on those
computers we moved to the computational
science
era and today with that big data that we
need to uh
to look at and get the scientific
knowledge from it
we are entering the fourth paradigm the
data intensive uh
science arena the data incentive science
uh
realm the challenges we are facing
in dealing with that data are numerous
uh
some of those challenges uh try are
tackled by
by something called e-research
basically uh people in e-research try to
create the tools
and capabilities that would allow
scientists data scientists in general
to be able to go to that big data and
apply models try to discover the
the consistency behind that that raw
data coming from
radio telescopes coming from genomic
experiments
coming from everywhere basically the
real
real world actually in general
is not as as nice and and perfect as
we want it to be and what has been
delivered by this e-research
look at very often like dancing birds
basically
tools that can be useful
only to very very few people
a minority of geeks like particle
physicists
can go and handle a grid and use it on a
daily basis
to run large experimentation but what
about the other
scientists what about biologists what
about bioinformaticians what about
social scientists
all these people were not able
with the tools that have been built so
far with the capability that have been
built so far to to really
be empowered get to do the work they
need to do
by tackling the challenges related to
big data
uh so in order to uh
to to to face these challenges that are
now
actually the the challenges data science
is becoming
probably the hottest subject and is is
is required everywhere it's not only
about
science it's also about finance it's
also about
you know optimizing
business strategies it's about
everything so
the data science becoming the hardest
subject we needed really to look at the
landscapes
of tools currently available and try to
see
whether we can find some consistency
and fight against what kills
the productivity and what prevents
people from doing what they have to do
which is
the fragmentation the fragmentation
means that
the data is available in formats that
that
are not interoperable the the tools we
use to tackle
uh the analysis are all different
some most of you of course all of you
here use python
some use r other use matlab
other use mathematica those tools
deliver capabilities
but they don't work nicely together
the idea was to say can we try to make
these tools collaborate interact and
and work together for us in consistency
the other so one image i like
to describe the goal we would like to
achieve is to make
data science accessible to a
a boy and and this is not a complete
fiction think of what happened in the
electronics arena
i i don't know how many of you uh know
about arduino or raspberry pi
so everyone knows about these widgets
very very cheap widgets allow you
whether you know electronics or not to
go and
and build something sophisticated
because someone
lowered the barrier for you someone made
the capabilities of electronics
encapsulated wrapped in a way that allow
you to just
go and pull the different components put
them together
and build the sophisticated system that
used to be
completely uh the how to say
the domain of experts and the domain of
electronicians and the domain of people
who went
to school and had a degree in something
specific
and basically that's the dream the dream
is to
to make uh data science democratized
by delivering something that that's that
that is similar
to arduinos and raspberry pi and of
course to build these things virtually
we need a lot of technology
of course python is one of them cloud
computing is by
part of that and r is part of that and
i'll show you
uh during this presentation how we can
go
to to this kind of utopia
i mentioned cloud computing and of
course
everyone here heard of cloud computing
and everyone here heard of amazon
and people think of cloud computing as a
way to go
and grab compute and storage capacity
on demand and and pay them for the use
and then just release them when you are
done
but it's not all what cloud computing is
about
for me uh cloud computing uh has
the power to produce in the it arena
what 3d printers could produce
in the real physical world think of
what a 3d printer can deliver to you
a 3d printer can allow you to go and
grab a script
that describes a physical object
and make that script become real
you can go and visit a friend and see on
his table
uh an object uh that that you like
you ask him how did you get this you say
ah i will share with you the script on
facebook and by sharing that script on
facebook you can go home
and build with your 3d printer exactly
what the object that you have seen
cloud computing is exactly the same
thing it's like a huge 3d printer for
computer science components and
services that you can describe and
produce
from a script so i can give you
a list of function calls
that you can go and give to amazon
and amazon will produce for you servers
storages software components
links them together and deliver for you
the back end of your financial startup
you see and when when you have used that
back end and and
finish the work you have to do you just
go to amazon and push a button
and just get that infrastructure
collapse
so basically a script allowed you to
build something very sophisticated it's
it's as magical as going from a script
on facebook to a 3d object you put in
your house
it's uh it's as if you can go to uh to
see an architect
he uh to ask for a new house
he would just draw for you the 3d model
and ask you when where the house should
be built
and by pushing a button the house
becomes real you use it for
half a day and then you just get rid of
it
to build another one that's that's
that's extremely powerful
that's what the cloud for me is about
mostly beyond the economic uh
and beyond the fact that it's it makes
high performance computing completely
accessible to everyone
so these are the ingredients
to reach that goal you know data science
for everyone
of course the ingredients are not enough
we need to design on top and with these
ingredients
something that allows
to manipulate those widgets that anyone
can create
and share with others and that anyone
can go discover
and reuse so basically for this purpose
i i built on top of amazon
a platform uh actually it's not just
amazon it's started on amazon but it
could be deployed on any infrastructure
whether it is a public cloud or
a private cloud or even a simple cluster
that infrastructure actually comes this
this software basically uh
allows you to uh to define uh
components of course you are familiar
with the components that
uh that are uh that are the modules
coming from python
or or the elastic or the r packages so
those components uh
is this is anyone uh
does anyone have a laser pointer this
one doesn't seem to work
no yeah and
not a problem so i will i'll just point
uh
so basically uh what what the power of
python
the power of r is to allow you to have a
kind of platform
where your code or functions can be
wrapped
and delivered as something that people
can go and grab
and and include in their own
environments so basically sharing
a computational code sharing algorithms
sharing
really capabilities for dealing with
data becomes extremely easy
it's like a usb key that comes with the
capability that you plug
into your python platform and it becomes
more sophisticated it has more
capabilities the idea is to say
can we do the same thing with
computational resources with servers
is it possible to imagine that the cloud
will look like a usb plug
like i would plug electricity then i
would plug the cloud
and use it seamlessly and use it as
easily as i use a python component or
an r package so this is the aim of this
connector i would like computational
resources to be something that i can
really go
and hook to the idea is also to do this
with data
can i make data appear as if it is a usb
device that they plug to a huge platform
for data analysis
so basically by defining these different
contracts
the computational components that would
be really wrapping
a capability for processing data the
computational resources that
is actually wrapping an infrastructure
the storage contract that would allow me
to say my data is on stream or my data
is on this ftp server all my data is
on my local storage all this
if it happens will look like the arduino
or the raspberry pi walls
where you have kits and those kits can
allow you to make your
arduino connect to the internet or to
make your arduino pilot
the stores or or pilot your racing
car right so this is this is how we
uh are moving forward to this objective
of
bringing data science to everyone
so of course uh uh i mean i'm going to
use
a metaphor to to explain further uh
these different contracts
i showed you in the in the earliest uh
slide
when it comes to big data the challenge
is that
we can't move the data anymore to our
local machines to to deal with it right
so everyone is saying since we can't no
cannot move the data
we need to take the computation to the
data and that's
this is something that you do every day
if if the big data in your company or
the big data in your lab
is stored somewhere you would connect to
a server
that has directly accessed the data and
you would do that with a remote desktop
or you would do that with a kind of a
shell
that that just connects you to the
operating system and you issue commands
that's a way to take computation to the
data
and basically remote desktop and
remote session or remote shells
i think those are good but not good
enough and we can do better
one of the the ways to do better is
ipython
many of you use ipython i guess remotely
and that's that gives you much much more
flexibility
than really using a remote desktop
tool or use just you know a
linux shell okay so the idea is to say
uh
ipython is the way to go but what is
ipython
a python basically is an application
that delivered to your browser
the interactive component that allows
you to pilot a say a
and a python session running somewhere
okay
so you can think of that uh python
session running somewhere as like
a robots that understand python
that can be sent to the data and that
you take
control over from anywhere anywhere
because of the ubiquity of html5 could
be your computer could be your i
your your mobile phone could be anything
okay
so so far so good
what we need to do is to generalize the
ipython model
to say what about making this
idea of remote compute engine robot for
data analysis
encapsulate and become a way to access
everything that needs to be done next to
the data
basically we need to invent something
that would
look like a kind of submarine robot
that can be sent where the data is
and that we take control over from our
browser
from our excel from any application we
have locally
so it's it's basically we would like to
go
farther than ipython
so this is how things would look like if
we
create those remote data science engines
or computational
engines on amazon so this is uh this is
amazon
these are virtual machine instances
that you can start using the console of
amazon
and we need a system that allow us not
to create
simply instances of servers
but to get on those instances
these tools or these engines that
have the knowledge the know-how to
expose to the web
or to expose to any application on your
local machine
python are matlab anything so basically
we need to create
these software capabilities
and get them a remote controllable
by browsers and potentially when we have
this
in hand we can enable their control
to become collaborative so basically the
ipython session
you would be connected to from your
browser could be
shared the way a document could be
shared
on google docs so many of you are
familiar with google docs capabilities
you go
and create a word document or you create
a spreadsheet
and you say this spreadsheet should be
visible to paul peter and
and martha okay and all of you in real
time in synchronous
way uh start working with the cells
updating the cells looking at what
others are doing
so basically the idea is to enable that
for the control of these remote engines
for data science
okay
so if we create this obstruction we
can also end up by having something
that makes the heterogeneity of
infrastructure
less important so all of you are
probably familiar with all the
uh the difficulties one gets in
installing software in on a linux box
and then moving
to a solaris system and then going to
windows
all that friction uh exists also in the
cloud computing arena and the clouds are
mini clouds you have of course amazon
the most important
but you have a microsoft cloud as well
it could be a cloud you build
on your own infrastructure using uh a
private cloud toolkits
like uh eucalyptus or openstack or
whatever
so basically the idea is that we are
going to live in a world
where the friction is not only about
operating system
but also about infrastructures that are
different
that that respond differently that needs
some
kind of specific know-how and technology
so the idea of these remote engines of
com of computation or or
these these robots of data science the
idea is that to get them
look and respond the same way whether
they are running on amazon or on azure
or on your local system so basically to
remove that friction
of of having a heterogeneity through the
the the machines and and platforms you
are using for running your computation
so it's basically saying we are going
to federate clouds by building on top of
the clouds infrastructures that expose
the computation
with a standard contract the contract of
the computational engine
so this is uh again
a python is an example of what can be
done
but we need to generalize the model to
reach this
this this kind of
universe so now
uh everyone here knows that when you
talk about the cloud
we talk about images that become
servers and those images are stored
somewhere
and i can at any point in time when i
have a running machine
make it snapshotted and become an image
that gets stored on the cloud itself
this is also extremely powerful this is
this is what enables
the so-called 3d printing metaphor for
the cloud
so basically these images
can be a way for you to get
others reproduce what you have done with
your compute engine
so imagine that you have done some work
with data
that used a specific version of python a
specific version of
panda a specific version of a data set
and then you need to publish a paper
about
your work or you need to share with
colleagues what you have
produced as artifacts so in order for
your colleagues to be able
to do again what you have done it's in
general complicated you
need to tell them exactly what version
of each uh package what version of each
tool has been used
where's the data how's the data dealt
with all that
is is easy to capture if you work on the
cloud
by using snapshots and virtual machine
images
so imagine now that those computational
robots
would leave on images and anyone
when when when needing to do some
work in python in r or whatever would go
to a system and say
okay i would like a robot with this
description
it should know about this version of
python it should know about this
version of r and it should have this
capacity
so basically the system will go and grab
from this library of capabilities
that is actually in in in reality
virtual images
make it become a server gives you
control you do your work virtually
and when you have finished your work you
can communicate
the information about the environment by
just saying to your
colleague or to the reviewer of the
journal look
i have used the image with this
identifier
let's say the red image and my data is
on this
blue disk so that's a way to make
others able to reproduce exactly what
you have done
in this particular environment so this
uh this was a kind of long uh
presentation about
where we would like to go and how we
would like we are going to achieve it
so i will switch to a demo to to show
you how this
becomes real and how we can get this to
work on amazon for example
so i'm going to connect to this platform
that
sits between me and the clouds
i'm going to ww www.elasticr.com
so uh elastic like elastic and
r.com and i'm going to sign in
i invite you to to to register and
create accounts
for for the later for for demoing uh
the collaboration and showing you how to
use it so
here i am basically it's a portal
combined with with this platform for
piloting the engines
i'm going to connect basically sign in
do we have internet
yeah we do
uh
let me see
so internet is there okay here we go
is the car is not responding i slow
still loading so let me try to go
directly to the console
sdr
okay
does it is any does anyone
manage to connect that's a pity
okay
um
okay the machine is not even responding
yeah in the meantime just
so i will reboot the system and
okay
this is unfortunate
okay
what's going on
i will switch to my own internet i don't
know what's what's going on really
okay there you go
this is a pity
and
yep
i will take 5-10 minutes to reboot the
the system and
everything should be fine hopefully
uh
so basically there is an issue in
connecting to a remote server
all right i'm just
i see
it's it's not it's not a big deal i
think it's gonna be
okay here we go okay
okay that's now up
okay here we go
everything should be fine now let's go
there we go
okay there you go so basically
uh so it's the the the apache
nodes failed but uh now it's back to
to normal life so basically uh what i
will show you
now is how we can get uh to
use the cloud of amazon easily by
simplifying the
the the control and the console of the
cloud access
and how we can require the creation of
engine for data science
using a python r or whatever tools you
want to use
and and how we can get those tools to to
to be
shared and and how we can really have
collaboration
within this virtual environment so
basically
uh once connected you can go uh and and
register
uh who here
in the audience who managed to to get
connected now
one two three four so basically you have
a registration link
and you can create an account uh
now i'm going i'm connected and i will
uh
move directly to this uh to this console
that would allow me to create engines on
amazon and and to work with them
from within the browser
so what we need to do first
is to hide the complexity of the cloud
by giving the the end user a way to
describe describe the need
extremely easily to say i would like to
work with python i would like to
work with r i would i would like to
teach with these tools or i would like
to do a
scientific research with these tools so
the first step is actually
to simplify the the console of amazon so
if instead of exposing the entire cloud
we would just
expose this simple interface here
where we ask the user to to tell us
where
what infrastructure he or she would like
to use so here you can specify amazon or
you can specify
the the cloud of microsoft azure or it
could be just your
own private infrastructure when you have
specified infrastructure you give your
credentials
to elastic r you say this is my login
password to amazon
then you have a combo box that actually
references those
machines in color the red machine the
green machine the yellow machine
here a machine basically refers to
capabilities so if you would like to
work
with a particular version of r or a
particular version of
python it would be available in this
kind of
library of of kind of frozen services or
or pre
pre-provisioned capabilities so i can
for example say
okay i would like to work with centos
and i will use the version the last
version of r and version 2.7 of python
the system goes to the cloud that i have
chosen and
and checks the capabilities
in term of capacity memory storage
that that are compatible with this this
particular image so for example if i
would like to run
these capabilities with plenty of memory
for example
let's say i would like to have 68 gig of
ram
uh and an eight cores the system just
gives me a
an aggregation of information saying
this would cost you two dollars
and a half for one hour of use this
machine would be
extremely expensive to buy but if you
use it on amazon it costs that cheap
if i would like to use even more
sophisticated
capabilities for example uh i would like
to work
with super computing nodes so i would
take this image
that has scientific linux the latest r
and and you see here for example i could
run
with a machine of 245 44 gig of ram
32 cores and this would cost me three
dollars and a half per hour
so this is a machine potentially
impossible to buy
but for three dollars and a half you
would get it okay so
let's go back to reasonable things i i
will take this machine
and i will grab a capacity medium for
example four gig of ram
this let's say this is a machine i would
use for for having a teaching session
for of r or python then i will tell
elastic r to shut the machine
automatically for example after two
hours
i can specify here in the working volume
and reference volume
where's my data so basically i can
describe
a storage to the elastic r system and it
becomes just
a line in the combo box so it can refer
to my ftp server
it can refer to my bucket on s3 it can
be anything
and then i give the machine a label so i
can say okay
this is my machine demo for pi data
2014. and of course i need to give my
credentials
of amazon to the system so here i'm
going to say
this is the account i will be using
uh this is one of the accounts we have
that's it so basically as a user you
give your you choose your infrastructure
you you choose you give your credentials
you choose the capabilities you want
how much memory and how how many cores
a label and you push a button so that's
something that a high school student
could do right
so let's let's see if this will work
so the system goes to that particular
cloud and from my credentials
uh tries to retrieve the keys
the keys have been retrieved they are
used to start the machine that
appears here you see demo pi data and
the status of that machine is pending so
basically
the order has been given to amazon to
start the machine
and when it gets ready i'll be able to
connect to it from my browser and take
control
and have my virtual session without
leaving the same browser with the same
session the same virtual research
environment
so i have already a machine running
which has ubuntu
we will wait for this one let's say this
one is starting so
it went from pending to starting
and when starting means uh
it's preparing the engines so it's
running those
components that i will take control over
from within my browser
let's have a look ubuntu is
was unresponsive and now it's it seems
to be
back
yeah okay so uh why in waiting for that
machine
you see um i have here uh access
to that ubuntu server that i have
started just before the presentation
and here i have a
console that allows me to talk to any
capability that is
pre-provisioned on that server for
example if i would like to do
r coding i can type anything here for
example i'm defining a variable x
and a variable y
and i'm plotting x against y
so basically what i'm doing is be is
work handled by that engine that runs
for me on the cloud with that particular
capacity
and uh what is shown here is a virtual
device so i can describe virtual devices
for graphics on
server side and name them device 1
device 2 device 3
and ask the system the robot to send any
graphics i produce to those devices
i can switch from r to python
and here i'm i'm writing python code
so this is being answered by the
python personality of the engine so i
can switch from a personality to the
others
and all of them are living in the same
process so basically how it works
we have a kind of base a glue in java
to which everything is connected with
gni
so i have python connected with [ __ ]
i have r connected with air java i have
jython because it's java directly
embedded in the virtual machine
and then that java virtual machine is
exposed with rmi as a remote component
and then i have gateways in front of all
this
that take any commands and and dispatch
them to the right
process as required at any point in time
i can share this session
with with the uh collaborators and get
them to interact with me
uh of course this is just
uh the very basics of it uh
what is your uh login do have you
created the
uh can you write for me the login so
that i share with you
meaning uh the the screen name
uh or any anyone you have one
okay here we go i'm going to share with
artists my session so all i need to do
is
to go to collaboration and
here i will say are this i can be
specific on what rights i will give are
this
and just by telling the system that now
ardis has all these rights read write
execute you will have your browser
connect
automatically to the same session as
myself you see
you have joined and if you look in your
system you have the same console as
myself
and you can issue commands for example
it's uh it's getting connected when you
will get the session
we will be able to try to collaborate
yeah it's there here we go
so okay just open views here and click
on console and graphics
okay then open this one and here
just scroll down and type something for
example
a mean value of x
a n parenthesis x and
okay so you are computing the mean value
of x
uh you can use so basically those those
virtual devices has
have collaboration capabilities like for
example uh
you can use the white the white board so
just
put something here and and start drawing
so this is what you are looking at
and this data is odd and have a look at
this
so basically these capabilities on top
of the the
uh scientific graphics allow you to
interact
with your peer collaborators uh that
basically this can happen within a
classroom while teaching
you can get the the students engaged
in in the in the course by uh asking for
example john to show the audience
something specific
by asking uh natalie to do something
and that's that makes the the
interaction with the students a little
bit funnier
and and and probably the process of
learning more efficient
and in this collaborative environment uh
basically
i can have what i call the services
sheets so i'm going to
close the cloud console
and the console and graphics and focus
on this
so this space actually is a kind of html
space
where i can drag and drop widgets that
give me access to some
of the capabilities of the engine for
example if i would like to work
with r not from that simple console but
using rstudio
i will go and grab a widget
here we go
so this widget will connect me
to another studio session that runs on
that particular machine
i will be able to use rstudio from my
browser
so here we go this is rstudio
in the console i would be able to type
whatever
i typed earlier
and i will ask for the variance of x
so this is r studio if i would like to
use ipython
i can do it for probably in another
sheet
so here i move to sheet2 and i'm going
to
ask for ipython there we go
i will have a widget all this is
persistent of course if i disconnect and
come back
i will retrieve all my widgets and all
my services sheets and all
my collaborators will be able to see the
same thing as myself
you see here i have already two two
notebooks i will create a new one
and and i will start
working
nothing very very sophisticated
i can plot i can do whatever i do with a
notebook of course
and at any point in time so basically
anyone with whom i share these
capabilities
is is
if i save you will see immediately what
i have so
so basically by saving so everything i
have done
uh the the creation of widgets she is
my collaborator is seeing it on real
time so basically
can you just pick the the upper part of
the notebook and move it
just by uh okay just to demonstrate that
actually it's really what's going on and
basically i can create any number of
these
sheets and put in them widgets that
allow me to access capabilities that are
running on that remote
machine i will close uh the uh or let me
switch
to the sheet three and
uh so
this is uh here we go i'm going to close
ipython
and create a another widget
among the widgets there there are a
variety of things like so for example
this one
is simply a virtual desktop
so here i i have a virtual desktop to
that server
that allows me actually to run anything
it could be a binary code on on the
machine
that i am connected to and start
basically the sky is the limit in a way
you can imagine widgets of all kinds
now i would like to show you something
that go even farther
so now we are having just virtual
environment that is collaborative
but we can imagine uh making this
a system for quickly designing and
delivering a science gateway
dashboards analytical applications just
on the fly
so i will close the html5
part and open
so let me probably get rid of this first
and i'm going to external tools i'm
going to start
the widgets designer the widgets
designer basically is an application
in java that it becomes a client of this
remote engine i have in the cloud
and i can with that widget designer
interact
or connect my variables to visual
components
that can change them so here we go
the visual designer is like the browser
just talking to the same engine
in this designer i can for example
define a variable in r let's say
i'm defining a variable n equal 10. i
would like
a slider that allow me to play with n
without being a software developer or
knowing java or anything i can just go
and right click and ask for a widget
that is a slider the widget is described
by in the r language
itself so slider dot make i say
the slider should pilot my variable n
apply and here we go i have a slider
that allows me to play with n if i look
at the value of n
in r it's equal 61. if
i change the value of n in r
to 35 the slider will change
and if my peer collaborator changes n so
if you go
and and here in the console say n equal
something
so the something is there okay so any
any connected clients
is creating changes on that
computational engine
and the changes are broadcasted as
events
to anyone listening anyone listening
could be java could be your browser
could be a local python session could be
r
could be words so for example here i'm
going to
open a word document
that is created on the fly that will
embed the connectivity information
about the remote engine and here it
looks like a simple word document
but actually it has some vba that went
and connected to the clouds
to that same engine we are interacting
with and i can issue commands from my
wall
my my word document to the cloud so here
i'm
selecting a text i have typed
and with the key i send the command to
the cloud
it comes back to my word document it
says you have n
an x and y i will ask to see the
variance of x
and i will ask to have a histogram of y
so i could issue so here the histogram
is
generated on the cloud comes back is
injected in my word document
so it's it's basically uh you ubiquity
and convergence these uh this
abstraction of the engine means that i
am now able to connect
everything with everything okay
of course i could issue commands from
word to python to whatever i have
in the cloud i could do the same thing
i could do the same thing with excel
so here for example i'm asking for an
excel spreadsheet
and the excel spreadsheet will come
connect to the cloud
and allow me to remote control a
spreadsheet that
actually lives within the memory of the
engine and
is completely r enabled and python
enabled in a way
so let's have a look uh
yeah so that's the spreadsheet coming
i while while it's loading i will create
a widget
that will show that same spreadsheet
there we go
uh you see in this in this spreadsheet i
have
uh basically minimal capabilities like
the ones i have in excel
so i can i can in put variables
and i can use functions of r for example
i will define a function
f as being a
tech function as taking a variable x
and returning twice the mean of x
nothing very sophisticated
and now i will use the the that new
function in the spreadsheet in a formula
cell by
saying this should be f of a1 to a4
here we go so this cell is computed
using a function in r i have just
defined on the fly if i update
here of course the uh
the cell is computed and and comes to my
uh okay i will open the excel
spreadsheet
that will connect to the cloud and
become
becomes a a mirror of the the
spreadsheet i have been manipulating
earlier you see
so basically those are the values i have
just entered
and if i change a1 to
13 or 133 you see that cell is
recomputed recomputed with what
you recomputed with the function f that
they have defined on the fly
in r i can of course send
this spreadsheet or the word document
directly with any
in within an email or put a link to it
and anyone can have this this capability
of accessing the real data
remotely and collaboratively
of course it's it's in in a
bi-directional
the value i have entered in excel
is is seen here as well okay
uh i can go even farther i can say
these cells a1 to a4
i will map them with a variable in
r let's call it z so now
these cells are active
anything that would happen to the
variable z so this is uh
the variable z if i change the the the
first element or the second element of z
to become equal to uh
44 you see here
z is is completely mapped this is a
mirror of the variable i have
i will ask for a widget that will show
me a bar chart of that
so here we go new
new chart
so this is a bar chart of z and
if i change the value here
the bar chart updates because it's a
mirror of the variable z
if i use excel to update
the cell to 44
the the chart updates as well now i can
uh i can connect for example my variable
n to z with the model i say z is a
function of n
uh i can do that with the macro so it's
it's like
a kind of excel that has been sent to
the cloud and that became completely
programmable uh consistently
programmable
in the r language and a completely
linked and and a completely mirroring
the the data of
r so i can create this macro here
new macro uh my macro is going to be uh
listening on n and we'll have an action
uh
like this will recompute z
as being n times
air norm of four
so basically i i'm describing a macro in
the r language
that will be listening this is the
condition of trigging the macros
and this is the action recompute z as
being n
times a norm of 4 apply
so what will happen now if n changes
so are you still connected
my peer collaborator so just change n
put say n equal 55 or something i have
this kind of interface here yeah yeah
just type in don't see that
yeah you don't need to you just because
we are talking to the same robot
so if you say n equal 15 or 20 or
anything
yeah so the change of n
triggered a change of the widget that
shows n
and triggered the macro that recomputed
z as a function of
n z appeared in the bar chart and was
injected in the spreadsheet
so we have created in no time in
an interactive collaborative dashboards
that can be delivered with a simple url
so i can ask
for the delivery url a url here you go
so this url is something i can send
to anyone and by opening that url
there we go what what you get
on your computer is that interface i
have designed for you this could be i
could be the bioinformatician
the person who will click on the link is
the biologist
he doesn't know r he doesn't know python
he just knows
that if he plays with parameter p he
should see something like this
so basically it's it's making the
interaction
so this is what what the biologist would
get
so an interactive interface where he can
play with parameter n
and see the changes in the spreadsheet
and of course
because all this is real time and is
collaborative
i can update what the biologist is
seeing in real time so i'm going to
to change the location of widgets
here we go so
what what the biology see so basically i
am i i created delivered an interactive
interface based on our python whatever
tools are required on server side
delivered it
in no time with the url and and make it
updated
on on real-time as well
now even more interesting i told you
that the cloud
is about scriptability infrastructure
becomes a program
okay so in order for this to be complete
we need python or r to be able to script
all this
everything i have done should be
accessible from the python command line
should be able to create this widget
from python command line i should be
able to
to connect to the remote engine and do
anything
like updating the spreadsheet or
whatever so let's try to see
that i'm going to to
open a standard r session and usually
use a package called elastic r
so this is a package you can download on
on the website and it will be on cran
so the the package is uh basically
a client to this platform so uh i will
say uh to the package
to connect me to the portal so here
portal.connect
and this is me
so my password here we go
so the the system is connecting me
to the to the platform and i will get a
session
normally
if it works
okay there we go so i i have a session
that makes my local r able to talk
to the portal for example i can say hey
portal can you show me the available
engines so
portal dot
find engines
so you see i have two
i will show you the data of the two and
you will recognize
that one of them is actually
the ubuntu machine and the other is the
demo pi data
that i have just started so i can take
control over one or two or both of them
i will take control over the first one
here we go engine dot connect
and probably i will put the information
about the engine you see
so the description of the engines comes
to my local
r as a data frame so it's an
information that i can manipulate
scriptability is not just
calling functions but also having access
to the artifacts as objects
that can be transformed so here we go
i'm going to put
uh the list of engines in my e variable
and then i will ask to connect to the
first one
engine.connect
so i extracted just the first line of
the
the first line of of the the data frame
so the connection is being established
and they create now i'm connected
i will show you that i'm really
connected by saying engine
engine dot
dot console for example
show me the variables i've got
and of course f n and x
i can talk to python of course i can say
hey python
uh tech can you compute
for me this print five
times four so let's see
the call
the call to the python personality seems
to be taking more time than it should be
okay that's not an issue
let's try to do the same thing while
it's
trying to get the action done from
a python session running locally here we
go
python
library no of course
import
import from
elastic or import a to star from
sticker import
so i'm i'm importing all the sim i'm on
our guy
import from elastic are important star
right
from elastic r import
star there you go i will have
that function that allows me to say
portal
connect
kareem dot chin
i'll show you my password very complex
one
and and now i'm going to get the
connection from within python itself
here we go and from within python i will
say
a portal
find engines
and it will retain a return the data
frame to python that
that lists the engine i will connect to
the to to the to the two engines
i will say uh engine
let me put this in a variable e equal
and engine connect
to it there you go the connection is
being created
and now i should be able to
okay the creation succeeded i will now
do a send a command engine
dot eval
n equal 44
okay so let's have a look now
uh so probably uh the command was issued
yeah that one is not responding
unluckily
so you see the command they have i have
issued to change n to 44 from python
updated the end that is there i have
clients in java in in c sharp in
whatever so basically
uh the platform has a soap and restful
api
and the engines have a soap and restful
api so you connect using the soap
api to the platform and say give me the
engines you take the coordinate the the
connection information of the engine and
use the other soap
to connect and remote control the
capabilities of the engine on the cloud
yeah so let's go back to the slides
and to see how this connects to what i
showed you
earlier so basically
the vision was about putting on top
of amazon or any cloud something
that would allow anyone to come with
empty hands
create a virtual infrastructure for
data analysis and
take control over it do something create
variables push
data on top of the variables models and
data create
an application deliver it and share it
with others
so basically it's it's it's having
anyone fully control and master the
entire
uh process of producing
a data science artifact from scratch
of course because these machines are on
amazon they can be
super computing nodes they can be really
very very strong
computational capabilities this
immediately applies to big data
in a way this applies to big data
because i have these
these super powerful nodes but it
applies also to big data
because in i can pilot one engine but i
can
pilot a thousand in the same with the
same
ease of use i could have started 100
machines
i could have listed the the engines on
all those machines
and they could have sent something to be
done in parallel
on amazon base sharing the data between
all the engines available and getting
the results back and aggregating
all that is available in that package
that is available for r and
python so uh
ideally uh one these once
the the packages are are out there in in
few weeks
they will be here they will be
accessible as i said
on cram and and on the website of
elastic r
you just go and and give it a try so
you you can immediately go and register
www.amazon.com create an account when
you create the account
you will have something called tokens
the tokens is an an interesting
abstraction
for getting someone who doesn't have a
cloud account
to use it so imagine uh imagine a
teacher
who would like to give a course to
students so
the teacher starts by creating a session
like the one i showed you
and that session could be shared with
student without having accounts
now in the students go back home and
need to practice
you cannot ask the student to use their
money right
that's not that's not acceptable that's
not
compliant with the policies so what you
can do
is go to the system and create what i
call
elastic tokens it's like virtual money
stating that that
that group of student is allowed to run
a machine
for a particular time for example if i
if i go back to my browser
uh here we go
where's my browser yeah
if if i close this view and open the
cloud console
you see here i i could use share tokens
so here i don't have any shared tokens
but if you create an account you will
see here
two tokens that allow you to run a
particular instance with a particular
capacity
for two hours so you just pick the token
and click on launch and that will run a
machine on amazon
with with of course the credential of
someone who is the one who will pay it
will be me because
the token will embed the keys that
my keys of amazon that's something that
anyone can do for anyone
so if you have an account on amazon you
can say
deliver a hundred token to this group of
collaborator or researcher or students
imagine now you go to coursera and would
like to take a course of python or r
of course you have the material you have
the videos you have
the exercises but it it there is a lot
of friction related to the fact that you
need to install
things and you need imagine now that the
in coursera there is a button you click
on it
and that button consumes a token creates
for you
a session that is exactly what the
courses requires
you know that contains the scripts the
data everything related to what people
need to practice
so basically in no time you have in your
browser what you need to
to to work with and at any point in time
you can share it with the other students
of the same course and and get uh get to
solve problems collaboratively or
or share the session with the teacher in
order to get some
help and guidance so basically the
applications are not only
in collaboration within research groups
but also in remote education in in
uh yeah and and with this
uh tokens stuff we kind of complete the
circle
we end up with a platform where where
what can be done
is really without limits so it's it's
it's something uh
that allows you in fact not only
to use those standard tools you have but
to make everything
become a widget that you put on the
table for someone to
reuse it and that widget could be not
only you know scripts and functions
but could be something that wraps very
very sophisticated
capabilities i will conclude by showing
you one of
those very very sophisticated
sophisticated capabilities so let me go
and grab again the widget designer
so the widget designer as i said is is
where a place where i can grab widgets
and put them
in a kind of white board of services
and and and share that wide board of
services but those widgets are not
limited to
what you have anyone can come and
describe his own widget
so i will show you uh two widgets that
have
been created in the system by a
computational chemist
i will go to sheet2 i will ask for a
spreadsheet pain
and computational chemists describe
their
molecules and compound with what they
call smiles
it's text strings that describe complex
stuff
so for example this is a molecule that
has three carbons
when they have a compound they would
like to see it in two dimensions
so the computational chemist created the
function in r
that wraps a tool that generates from
smiles
the 2d description that function is
called smiles.image
so he goes and says smiles.image
of a1
and the dimension should be 200 by 200
it's a1 sorry
so you see here we
have a um a formula that this
that returned as a result a 2d of course
if i change the molecule
i will add the carbon
uh the change happens in real time then
he created
another uh function in r that wraps
uh a tool called jmol jmol is a tool in
java open source that allows you to see
the
the molecules in three dimensions so
here we go
the function is called smiles.jmod
of a1
so what you see is this the formula
return
the description of an application that
shows you this molecule in three
dimensions
of course it's it's not a toy if i if i
ask
to see smiles from the web let's say of
complex molecules
let me see for example the the nicotine
nasty molecule here you go
i will uh i will put it here
so the system in no time goes grabs the
2d dimension and this is the 3d
representation of the and of course this
is something i can share
immediately so again to tell you that
this is is a framework where we would
like to consistently
gather all the capabilities that
scientists and educators
use in the data science arena and and
make them
capable of of really doing on their
own things so basically would like to
remove the computer scientists from
from where we can by automating things
in order to end up
by having high school students became
become
data scientists and i will conclude here
thank you very much for your attention